so viel bitrate, schlecht für internet in deutschland
des krebsen, ja
what the hell
was, was, was, was empfiehlt mir youtube da
oh gotts, youtube ist so voll mit scheiße irgendwie
what the fuck
was, was seh ich da
so unglaublich bescheuert
ja dann
ich frag mich
was, was ist in dem seinem kopf vorgegangen, als der sich das erst, als der das erstellte
dann hat er sich gedacht, ah ja jetzt lass ich meine katze saria song miauen
alles klar
what the fuck
der bot funktioniert, was macht der bot denn
oh ich seh grad
was es gibt nun ein aiya ja emote und der bot ist nun cute, ja cutebot ist schonmal gut
achja es ist nicht aiya ja es ist ai ai ai ai ai oder was
oh ich sehe schon hier big brain naming wieder am start
so ich weiß nicht warum das youtube mir jetzt empfohlen hat aber youtube hat es gedacht
des muss man jetzt unbedingt gucken
by the way wer es noch nicht mitgekriegt hat
ich hab heut tatsächlich ein neues video hochgeladen
hab ich auf fiver bestellt, exellent
und ging schnell, wo hast du bestellt
in indien oder irgendwo anders
guck mal ich hab heut, ich hab heut ein video hochgeladen leute
jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt nicht zusammen an, weil das wär echt schon bisschen videoception
wenn ich das video was ich heut morgen aufgenommen hab mir jetzt mit dem chat noch mal angucken
würde
aber in kanada da passt ja eigentlich, die haben doch
von der zeitzone her müsste es eigentlich dann ganz gut passen
ja 10.000 views seit ich hab es heute heute mittag hochgeladen 13 14 uhr oder so
haha patrick gäbe ich dir recht
weißt du was ich hätt das bei dem dort wo ich die sache zum programmieren beauftragt
hab in fiver das hätt ich auch gemacht
hättet es einer gut gemacht dem hätt ich ohne scheiß 50 euro um drauf
gegeben weil ich mein für die für die paar cent was die da reingeschrieben haben
kein wunder das ist ne aber nachdem das ja so ein kompletter reinfall war
hab ich das nicht gemacht
das war ja totaler fail ne als ich das auf fiver beauftragt hab zu programmieren
also für die für die alle die das nicht kennen wir haben im stream mal was programmiert
zusammen so ein chat
ne twitch chat mit log tool also nichts kompliziertes das hat sich in twitch chat eingeloggt und
geguckt ob was an mich geschrieben wurde hat es dann auf der webseite geschrieben also
wie gesagt das waren 100 zeilen code inklusive frontend das war wirklich wenig ja und das
hab ich beauftragt auf fiver bei 12 verschiedenen
programmierern ich hab natürlich nur die billigsten genommen zum größten teil irgendwas
aus indien irgendwelche leute aus indien und ich hab halt immer die leute genommen die
geschrieben haben ins profil dass sie complete application erstellen und sonst was halt für
7 euro 78 ok aber es war nur müll dabei
bestell mal emotes für max dann wirds endlich was ja wahrscheinlich
ja die sache ist die du kannst ja nicht für mich emotes bestellen das passt ja nicht
wahrscheinlich hab ich ganz andere vorstellungen das das das funktioniert nicht aber wahrscheinlich
ohne mist wahrscheinlich werden die emotes sogar besser als gar keine emotes also verschenkt
wärs wahrscheinlich auf jeden fall nicht
naja was was empfiehlt uns youtube denn hier noch schönes heute
2.0.w ja
was wäre
warte moment was was schreibt der reaktionist das habe ich nicht gecheckt das wäre ein
gemeinsamer stream mit dem entwickler von killzigs für ne was sollen wir denn da streamen
ich glaube nicht dass das sonderlich spannend ist da sind irgendwelche lua scripts wie man
der vernies unleashed modded
kann dir sagen was willst ich hab ne richtig weißt du was wir machen können ohne mist
also wenn du dir das dichter sache wirklich ein bisschen annehmen willst können wir folgendes
machen ich hab ne lange liste mit emotes die passen würden also die habe ich mir schon
bestimmt über den jahr lang überlegt
und bei manchen habe ich auch so ein bisschen ideen wie das ganze ausschauen soll ich schicke
dir das einfach mal aber wie gesagt ne das ist jetzt nichts wo unbedingt da in den nächsten
paar wochen was rauskommen muss oder so ansonsten ich hab ja auch so nix
aber schicke ich dir
bei vielen habe ich halt auch absolut keine idee ne was emotes angeht weil ich weiß halt
auch gar nicht in welchem style die sein sollen das so das problem
mit keks ohne keks mit irgendwas anderem das ist wirklich ich bin da sehr unkreativ deswegen
hätte ich ja am liebsten jemand der sowas designed mit dem er auch reden kann so ganz
normal auf deutsch und nicht irgendein inder oder so der am anderen ende der welt sitzt
und irgendwas malt
ja das wäre natürlich nice und ich sage poggers wäre das poggers
leute wisst ihr was mir heute passiert ist im video
ich wollte irgendwas sagen was ich hab ein wort gesucht für besonders toll und mir ist
nichts eingefallen außer poggers ich weiß nicht ob es euch aufgefallen ist
irgendwo irgendwo hier glaube ich
hier jetzt kommts mir ist kein wort eingefallen absolute nice poggers basis ist nix eingefallen
ich wollte irgendwas sagen ich wollte halt sagen dass es eine richtig geile basis hatte
das game und mir ist mir ist nichts eingefallen geil großartig super toll wahnsinn sonst
was das erste was mir eingefallen ist poggers basis
warframe kommt wohl auch ganz gut
so ist das wenn man zu viel streamt dann fällt einem kein anderes wort mehr außer twitch
emotes ein
die ganzen youtube oh nein die verstehen eh nix aber das war damals schon so
friseur und ich wir haben ja damals schon immer wildes das random englisch plus unsere
eigenen wortkreation plus durcheinander sinnloses gelaber gemacht das haben damals schon viele
leute nicht kapiert ich kann mich noch an die kommentare dran erinnern von damals max
das heißt cobra und nicht kodra alter kann sich da noch einer dran erinnern wir haben
immer gesagt wir haben zu diesem call of duty killstück wir haben nicht gesagt cobra das
war so ein heli sondern haben wir gesagt kodra so einfach aus spast an der freude es hatte
keinen sinn es hat das bedeutete auch nix ja und die leute haben bestimmt in jedem video
50 mal max das heißt kodra das heißt das heißt das heißt nicht kodra das heißt kodra
schreibt das doch mal richtig sagt das doch mal richtig ja die war schon geil heute hat
es übrigens ich muss doch mal das video aufmachen bei manche leuten weiß ich nicht ob das trollen
ist oder ob die das oder ob die das ernst meinen da waren wieder ein paar comments dabei
wo ich mir gedacht habe hier schon wieder amazon reklame was soll das wo war der amazon
reklame da ich gesagt habe das game ist gerade bald prime kostenlos oder was ich verstehe
es aber sind auch mehr so comments sind auch mehr so komische comments drin oh ja so prash
da war auch mal geflamed ja er hat recht
naja aber teilweise die leute echt ach ja und da hatte ich auch letztens irgendwie ein
no hate aber ich weiß echt nicht warum du noch videos machst
was genau sollen wir das video jetzt sagen aber aber no hate no hate warum heißt er denn
auf twitch nicht max fps er heißt auf twitch nicht max fps hat mehrere gründe und zwar
wollte er eigentlich gar nicht schrieben auf twitch er hatte sich nämlich in account erstellt
einfach zum twitch gucken und irgendwann hatte er sich dann überlegt er könnte doch
streben und habe ich den account genommen und außerdem habe ich mir dann gedacht ich
habe den max fps account ich habe ihn sogar reserviert auf twitch also wartet mal gibt
sie gibt es ja sogar also ich könnte sogar ich könnte sogar um switchen ich hatte mir
das damals registriert aber
ich dachte mir dann irgendwann so hey nachdem ich auf youtube eh nicht mehr so viel mache
und dazu kommt ja dass ich hier meistens zumindest komplett außer wenn wir ab und zu mal battlefield
spielen oder so meistens was komplett anderes machen dann ist es gar nicht so schlecht weil
auf youtube gibt es ja schon viele deppen wie man am youtube content auch sieht und da
habe ich mir gedacht ok dann kommen nur die gescheiten leute rüber also wenn du hier
auftauchst gehörst du eigentlich zu den gescheiten leuten weil die anderen checken es nicht nur
der chat genau exzellent so schauen wir mal was empfiehlt uns youtube denn geiles muss
ich gerade mal kurz durch scrollen ob da irgendwas sinnvolles dabei ist sonst ich habe noch ein
paar andere sachen die man gucken könnte
ja wenn das das ist ja keine kunst wenn der scheiß alt ist und sagt dann kriegt es auch
für 150 dollar kriegt auch in dem pentium 3 für 150 dollar mit schienen kein problem
wobei das ein bisschen besser wusste lange nicht dass du mal ein youtuber warst es sind
ja mittlerweile witzigerweise auf twitch auch viele leute am start die das von youtube gar
nicht kennen diese video sind teilweise übelst lustig guck jetzt hier nicht im stream an
die sind teilweise echt übelst lustig da nehmen sie immer irgendwelche clips von total verplanten
leuten machen äh elder scrolls musik drunter und planten den dialog unten ein und das
könnte halt originalen npc sein oh ja natürlich wer kennt es nicht ich meine ok
es gibt zwei möglichkeiten entweder wir sind in usa oder wir sind in russland in usa darf
man es wahrscheinlich legal besitzen in russland nicht aber da scheißen die leute drauf
aber kurz die musik ausmachen also haben wir ganz davon abgesehen ich glaube wenn
ein handgranat drin ist das kleinste problem was man hätte wäre dass mein inhalt vom
vom einkaufswagen brennt natürlich natürlich ein post bei selbstschussanlagen drauf dann
geht das wahrscheinlich oder oder der russler der russische style ist erstmal dashcams
überall dran machen soll ich mal aufgefallen dass die ganzen videos von irgendwelchen autos
die gegen pfeiler fahren oder oder irgendwo hängen bleiben oder dass sie alle aus russland
kommen das liegt daran weil da hat jeder irgendwie fünf dashcams ins auto drum herum
ahja
Klingt logisch, klingt logisch, klingt logisch.
Ah, Trophy-System, damit kenn ich mich aus, das gab's im Battlefield.
Oh, Moment, war das Battlefield? Nee, oder? Moment, ich bin verwirrt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht Battlefield.
Wo gab's das Trophy-System? Black Ops gab's das Trophy-System.
Oder MW3? Ich bring's grad durcheinander.
Ja, gut, gut, ist gut zu wissen.
Sehr gut.
Es ist mir ein bisschen viel Penetration gerade.
Was bin ich sehen? Das frage ich mich auch gerade.
Okay, ich kenn das, ich kenn das, ich kenn das.
Ich hab auch manchmal so kreative 5 Minuten, wo mir viel Schwachsinn auf einmal einfällt.
Und ich glaube, in diesem Modus hat sich das Hirn von dem Channel-Ersteller auch befunden.
Die Animation noch dabei.
Das sieht aus, als hätte er das in irgendeinem Level-Editor erstellt von vor 10 Jahren.
Ja, sind Schwachsinn. Aber Leute, jetzt haben wir ja, Chat, Chat, jetzt haben wir ja was lustiges geguckt.
Jetzt können wir was Panes-Champinges gucken.
What's new in PHP 8? Das wolltet ihr doch schon immer mal wissen, oder?
Gebt's zu. Ihr könnt's gar nicht erwarten zu erfahren. 46 Minuten lang was Neues in PHP 8.
Kannst du das nicht kurz zusammenfassen? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was neu ist in PHP 8.
Ich mach nix in PHP und ich hab auch nicht vor, was in PHP zu machen.
Haben die wieder die Hälfte umgeschmissen? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Es interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt doch überhaupt nicht.
Es, wisst ihr, was das Einzige ist? Was? Lass mal überlegen. Stimmt gar nicht. Stimmt gar nicht.
Chat, jetzt hätt ich euch ja fast angelogen hier. Überlegt euch das mal. Fast, fast misst erzählt.
Äh, ich hab zwei Sachen in PHP gemacht bisher.
Wie kommst du so spontan drauf? Einfach so.
Ähm, also ich hab zwei Sachen bisher in PHP gemacht. Und zwar, einmal, und das ist ewig her,
einmal, frag mich nicht, in 2003 oder so, hab ich mal Forumsignaturen gemacht für unsere Gruppe,
für unsere MMO-PvP-Gruppe. Also da konnte man sich seine Stats abfragen und sein Clantag und sein Name
und Klasse und Rang und alles. Und da hab ich für unsere acht Leute so eine Schwanzvergleichsignatur
gebastelt mit PHP. Also sprich, ich hab die Sachen abgefragt und hab dann halt das geupdatet,
einmal am Tag nachts. Und da kam dann halt ein PNG-Bild raus, was wir uns im Forum in die Signatur
gemacht haben. Und da konnten wir dann Schwanzvergleich machen, wer die meisten Leute mit noch
höheren Rängen hatte und so. Ja, das war das erste, das ist schon ewig her in PHP.
Und dann hab ich mal in PHP, als ich einen Battlefield 3 oder 4 Server hatte, als das neu war,
Battlefield 4 Server auf dem PC war das, als das neu war, hab ich mit Laravel damals und
na, MySQL-Datenbank, weil das das einzige war, was vom Host da unterstützt wurde, eine Stats-Seite gebaut.
Also sprich, da konnten die Leute sich angucken, wer hat die meisten Kills auf dem Server gemacht,
wer hat die meisten Scores, was ist das beste Squad und wer ist overall Kill-Leader und sowas.
War eigentlich richtig nice. Leider hatte ich eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf das Game.
Wie stolz er beim Erzählen ist. Ey, wir waren die geilste Gruppe auf dem ganzen Server, wir waren
excellent, ja. Aber leider interessiert das keinen mehr, ob man gut war in MMOs 2000, fragt mich nicht,
5 oder so, 3, 4, 5, 6 oder so. Juckt halt kein Mensch mehr, ne. Who cares. Das ist so, das ist so,
wie die Leute, die früher World First, World of Warcraft Bosskill gemacht haben oder so, ja.
Damals 50 Billionen Forum Threat und heute kann sich keiner mehr an den Charakternamen erinnern.
Das juckt keinem.
Naja, ok, schauen wir uns mal ein bisschen was an. Was haben wir denn hier schönes zu...
Warum hab ich jetzt dreimal YouTube auf? Guck mal, dreimal YouTube und die empfehlen uns fast überall das gleiche.
Ok, YouTube, letzte Chance. Zeig uns was Gescheites. Die Musik ist ein bisschen leise jetzt.
Nein, es gibt nix, es gibt nur irgendwelche Corona News, die mich hier auf YouTube absolut nicht jucken.
Das ist ganz einfach, nichts mit Rekursion machen, Problem gelöst.
Maxris, zwei Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, folgen wirs.
Fortunate, Fortunate, könnt mal gucken. Allerdings, das Problem ist, der spielt jetzt gerade Cold War, habe ich gesehen,
und flamet über Skill-Based Matchmaking rum. Und ich hab schon genug Flame Videos über Skill-Based Matchmaking gesehen
und ich hab auch schon genug über Skill-Based Matchmaking geflamed, was im Endeffekt heißt,
eigentlich müssen wir das nicht gucken, weil ich kann selbst auch eine halbe Stunde ranten über Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Und wisst ihr was das geile ist? Ich kann über Skill-Based Matchmaking flamen in einem Game, was ich nie gespielt hab.
Na doch, die Beta, zwei Stunden oder so.
Ich hab übrigens das Game jetzt installiert, da ist es, guckt's euch an.
Das wird das erste Call of Duty sein, wo ich nur Singleplayer spiele. Multiplayer game ich mir nicht.
Es sei denn, man muss wieder irgendwas leveln in Warzone oder so.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ich spiel mir da mal ein bisschen, jetzt, jetzt, warum ist der Sound jetzt so laut?
Die können das nicht richtig abmischen hier.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich spiel wieder ein bisschen Warzone, aber nicht im Stream.
Ähm, wenn die, fang ich schon mal wieder an, ein paar Runden Warzone zu spielen, wenn die Cold War und Warzone quasi merchen.
Was spielst du seit neuestem Jahr? Das Problem ist, es gibt ja nix.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit ein bisschen Path of Exile gespielt, allerdings haben sie jetzt den neuen Liga-Start verschoben.
Also wer sich mitgekriegt hat, PoE 3.13 kommt erst nächstes Jahr.
Und wisst ihr was die, ne Moment, drei, doch drei, wisst ihr, wisst ihr was das geile ist, was die Ausrede ist?
Warum die verschieben, die sagen, sie verschieben ist, dass die Leute nicht wählen müssen zwischen Path of Exile und Cyberpunk.
Was?
Was ist das für eine Logik? Also ich glaube, das liegt daran, entweder wollen die selber alles Cyberpunk spielen und haben keinen Bock.
Oder die haben halt Schiss, dass ihre League nicht gut läuft, weil die Leute alles Cyberpunk spielen.
Ich glaube, aus reiner Nächstenliebe verschieben die, verschieben die das nicht.
Cooles Video gestern. Ja, war was, ah nee, war nix dabei. Hätts mal richtig lesen sollen.
Tja, übrigens wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, ne, ich hab gestern, oder vorgestern, oder was war denn das, vorgestern,
hab ich ein Video hochgeladen mit 20 Tipps für Leute, die entweder selbst Informatiker, Techniker sind oder eben solche Leute waschenken wollen.
Ich finde, es sind 20 ganz gute Sachen dabei, die ich alle selbst hab und dementsprechend auch selbst bestätigen können, dass die was taugen.
Ähm, übrigens, was ich auch wieder geil fand, ne, es gab ja nicht viele Comments, da haben auch nicht so viele geguckt, aber ähm,
viele Comments gingen wieder darum, dass ich meinen Staubsauger geflasht hab, also da scheinen immer noch viele Leute nicht drauf klar zu kommen,
dass ich die Firmware von meinem Staubsauger flashe.
Lol, wie was, Staubsauger geflasht, hoho, was das, null Max, Staubsauger wie geflasht, Staubsauger, hä, die Leute sind voll verwirrt immer.
Darf der das überhaupt?
Der macht das einfach.
Wenn dann all die Werkzeuge kaputt geht, ja, also all die Werkzeuge kaputt zu machen, ist ganz einfach, du musst das einfach nur 10 Minuten lang anstarren, dann ist es kaputt.
So.
Also, die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind ja heute wieder absolut top notch.
Top notch und im Prinzip nix dabei, da gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal irgendwas anderes.
Genau, das, das brauch ich unbedingt zum Einschlafen.
Erstmal einer, der mir noch erklärt, äh, was genau eine Linked-List ist.
Ja, ich kann mir nichts besseres vorstellen zum Einschlafen.
Okay, also was haben wir denn hier, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Das, das, das, das könnte Monka, Monka Toss sein, wenn ich den Titel so lese.
Das ist gerendert, das ist nicht echt.
Es sieht aber verdammt echt aus, aber es ist nicht echt.
Ich glaube, da ist mehr als RTX on, ich glaube, da ist Rechencluster on.
RZ-Cluster im Rechenzentrum ist da on.
Oder 5 Wochen Rechnen ist on, eins von beiden.
Das sieht schon ziemlich gut aus, aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht echt.
Siehst du auch da hinten, wie sich die NPCs bewegen.
Schau mal, wie ex, wie exzellent es flutscht.
Richtig elastisch alles.
Das hat eine Woche Krähen mit Sicherheit.
Sowas rendert ewig.
Aber es sieht schon ziemlich gut aus, kann man sagen.
Warum spritzen die da immer, achso, das war es jetzt, immer Wasser zwischendurch runter.
Na okay, jetzt hat man erkannt.
Guck mal, wie die Dinger hier drüber slidern.
Aber nice, sieht schon echt nicht schlecht aus.
Es ist beeindruckend, was man mittlerweile alles machen kann.
Übrigens Leute, wenn ich solche Streams sehe hier.
Livestock Tracker.
Ich habe heute im Chat gesehen, dass irgendjemand bei unserem Discord auch sowas programmiert hat.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, ich bastel sowas noch so lange ich Urlaub hab.
Ich bastel auch so einen Livestock Tracker.
Und knall den voll mit Reflinks.
Und wenn die Leute quasi ihren Stock tracken und dann über meinen Reflink auf die Seite gehen, gibts Money. Easy.
Habe ich mir fest folgernommen, das baue ich noch im Urlaub.
Und ich habe mir jetzt eh überlegt, sagt sehr laut oder nicht sehr laut, ist mir egal.
Aber ich habe mir jetzt was überlegt.
Ich bin schon jahrelang immer wieder am rumbasteln und Sachen programmieren und tun und machen.
Und ich mache halt nur das, was mir halt technologisch gefällt und vom Projekt gefällt und sonst was.
Und ich habe mir jetzt vorgenommen, ich werde mal ein paar Sachen machen, die zumindest das Potential haben, ein bisschen Kohle zu generieren.
Es kann ja trotzdem sein mit irgendwas, was mir Spaß macht.
Ich werde jetzt da nicht irgendwelche BWL-Dinger programmieren oder so.
Stonks, genau.
Ich habe mir echt gedacht, man könnte doch mal was basteln, was zumindest das Potential hat, dass man ein bisschen Geld verdient.
Dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass ich ja eine gewisse Reichweite sowohl Twitter, YouTube, Twitch habe, dass man sowas halt auch mal erwähnen kann.
Und es ist ja dann auch nicht mal so, als kostet die Leute irgendwas.
Es kostet ja keinem was.
Und gerade so einen Tracker für, sagen wir, Verfügbarkeit von PS5, neue CPUs, neue Grafikkarten und sowas,
der dann bei den üblichen Verdächtigen guckt von Alternate, Amazon, Mindfactory und sonst was,
ob die Sachen verfügbar sind und dann einfach einen Link generiert, ist eigentlich vollkommen okay, das bringt allen was.
Und der Witz ist ja, mir ist klar, dass es dafür schon 30.000 Addons und Seiten gibt, aber wenn ich sehe,
dass Leute auf YouTube 1.500 sich den Gramm angucken, da ist auf jeden Fall Potential drin, dass die Leute das benutzen.
Das muss halt alles kostenlos sein, das muss angenehm zu benutzen sein.
Man könnte es sogar so machen, dass die Leute da drauf bleiben können auf der Seite
und dann kriegen sie irgendwie eine Audiobenachrichtigung oder eine Mail.
Aber für die Mail muss man sich opt in, sonst klappt es nicht.
Für die meisten Affiliate-Partnerprogramme brauchst du oft eine Webseite.
Ich bin ja Amazon-Partner, das reicht schon.
Es reicht, wenn ich genug Amazon-Reflinks unter das Volk bringe.
Der Rest von dem muss ich gar nicht großartig profitieren.
Ich habe jetzt dieses Video gemacht für Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Natürlich war das zwar nicht primär zum Money-Machen, aber ich habe es halt mit Reflinks gemacht.
Ja, Amazon-Zack, aber trotzdem, das gab es in zwei Tagen 80 Euro.
Mal gucken, was da noch kommt.
Und es haben nicht viele geguckt.
Ich hoffe ja, dass YouTube das vielleicht zu Weihnachten noch mal ein bisschen empfiehlt,
dass das noch ein bisschen mehr Leute sehen.
Also das Reflinkspammen lohnt sich übelst.
Serious Max, es muss halt etwas Legales sein, aber das klingt legal.
Was habt ihr an dir mal wieder letztens?
Achso, ich war so schlecht, dass sie direkt...
Tja, ich muss ein bisschen üben wieder.
Muss man nicht bei Reflinks einen Disclaimer schreiben, dass man bei keinem Klick profitiert?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das machen muss.
Ich hoste die Seite einfach in...
Keine Ahnung, Uganda oder so.
Und dann interessiert es keinen.
Was ist eigentlich die Top-Level-Domain?
Domain von Uganda.
Uck!
Alles klar.
Was kostet ein Uck-Domain?
Muss ich jetzt mal kurz überprüfen.
Keine Ahnung.
Poggers.Uck.
Kann man Uck-Domains registrieren?
Oh nee!
Die dürfen keine Uganda-Domains registrieren, das ist aber ein Fehler.
Na gut, dann nicht.
Vielleicht Sudan oder so.
Irgendwelche Länder, die es nicht juckt, was man da hostet.
Außerdem ist es ja gar nicht schlimm.
Ich werde ja eh die Sachen immer, also das mache ich ja eh,
ich gebe die Sachen alle komplett an, was ich verdiene.
Letztens wollte das Finanzamt von mir irgendwelche Sachen aus 2015 haben.
Was weiß ich denn, was ich 2015 da gemacht habe?
Aber zum Glück habe ich einen Steuerberater, der weiß das alles
und der hat alle Unterlagen da und kann das denen schicken.
Aber von 2015, ey, würde ich das selbst machen
und das Finanzamt kommt zu mir, da hätte ich keine Chance.
Da hätte ich keine Ahnung, was ich 2015 gemacht habe.
Deswegen mache ich das mit einem Steuerberater.
Aber nachdem ich eh alles immer angebe, ist da nichts.
Was da ein großer Mensch sein kann.
Was machen eigentlich der Kabum und der Friseur?
Denen geht es allesamt gut.
Der Friseur hat letztens ein Video gemacht,
da streamt er auch ab und zu mal.
Der Kabum streamt nicht, macht auch keine Videos mehr,
aber dem geht es auch gut.
Ja, sag mal, ich gucke jetzt mal irgendwas hier.
Zeig mal her.
Why games are massive?
Wortwörtlich, okay.
Warum sind Game Massives?
Gut, ich kann das im Prinzip schon beantworten,
warum Games Massive sind, weil mittlerweile heute
deutlich mehr unterschiedliche Sachen drin sind,
weil die Texturen größer werden, weil die Leute
teilweise keinen Bock mehr haben, Sound zu komprimieren.
Gerade Titanfall 1 war 50 Gigabyte, weil
schlecht oder unkomprimierter Sound drin war,
wo man sich denkt, what the hell, was macht ihr da schon wieder?
Alles Sachen, die relativ groß sind.
Und dazu kommt noch, ganz im Ernst, dazu kommt,
dass die in der heutigen Zeit auch gar keinen Bock haben, großartig.
Das Festplattenplatz mäßig zu optimieren,
weil es ist ja immer so ein Trade-off.
Also es gibt immer so einen generellen Trade-off zwischen
Speed und Platz, bei dem Fall immer fraglich,
je nachdem, wie stark das ist.
Aber in der Regel gibt es immer so einen Trade-off zwischen
wie groß ist was und wie schnell ist was.
Und wenn die sagen, hey, so können wir schneller Texturen streamen,
also können wir Sachen schneller laden und hier tun und machen.
Und die Leute haben heute eh 2 Terabyte SSDs plus,
dann kann ich das verstehen.
Gibt Verlust freie Komprimierung?
Ja, das gibt Verlust freie Komprimierung.
Die Dateien sind danach immer noch ziemlich groß im Vergleich
zu einem MP3 oder so, wenn es um Sound geht.
Und auch die braucht Leistung zum Decompressen.
Mal gucken, was er sagt.
Mal gucken, was er erzählt.
Ja, Titanfall war 50G groß.
Übrigens, ich hätte es Titanfall echt gegönnt,
dass das viel mehr eingeschlagen hat, wie es hat.
Ich glaube, dass, so doof es jetzt klingen mag,
ich glaube, das Problem für viele Leute waren die Titans an Titanfall.
Die Leute wollten eigentlich irgendwie eine richtig gute
COD-Alternative, gerade die, die keinen Bock mehr auf den ganzen Kram hatten.
Und das war es halt nicht so wirklich, ja.
Und Titanfall 2 kam zu einer ganz ungünstigen Zeit.
Kentucky Red fragt, Max, ich habe mal eine Frage.
Ich mache gerade eine Fachinformatiker-Systemintegration-Ausbildung
und möchte nach der Ausbildung Richtung Network-Engineer gehen
und in den späteren Zukunft DevOps.
Exzellent.
Cloud-Full-Stack-Sack-DevOps-Engineer.
Man kann ja heutzutage mittlerweile die üblichen Trendgeschichten
einfach hintereinander rein und rauskommt in eine Jobbezeichnung.
Also zertifiziere mich gerade in Python ab, schon den Entry fertig.
Warum geht denn das da immer nach unten?
Den Associate Programmer habe ich bald fertig.
Will dann noch die beiden Professional machen um die höchste Python.
Wo macht man das denn?
Ich kenne das überhaupt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es da Zertifizierung überhaupt gibt.
Danach ist der CCNA und CCNP dran auf dem Plan.
Ist das ein Vorteil bei Werbung?
Ja, das ist mit Sicherheit ein Vorteil.
Es ist halt immer der Frage, bei welchem Laden du landest.
Manche legen da sehr viel Wert drauf, bei manchen ist es nice to have.
Es schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob Zeit, Aufwand und was es kostet wert ist.
Das kann ich dir jetzt allerdings so nicht beantworten.
Aha, da macht man das.
Ich meine, CCNA an sich bringt nichts.
CCNA hat wirklich jeder Depp.
Ich auch.
Also ich hatte einen, das verfällt ja.
Sogar ich hatte einen CCNA.
Und ihr kennt mich, Chat.
Ich mache nichts freiwillig, was das angeht.
Sogar ich habe einen CCNA, als der, der nichts freiwillig macht.
Das sagt alles über Zertifizierung aus.
Bald gibt es auch Fachinformate in Richtung Datenprozesse.
Ja, ich weiß.
Haben wir letztens schon gelesen, aber die IHK.
Ich meine, CCNA ist garantiert abgelaufen.
Aber die IHK ist sicher nicht so ganz sicher, was die Dinger machen sollen.
Weil die Beschreibung auf der Seite von der IHK war recht gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Du bist Rosa.
Ja, siehst du mal.
Exzellent.
Hast du nicht?
Doch, habe ich.
Ich habe 2007 oder so Fachinformatikersystem Integration gelernt.
Ich hole ein bisschen her.
Und davor habe ich noch was anderes gemacht.
Davor habe ich so einen, so einen Ansatz, so einen Stonks-Job angefangen.
So eine Stonks-Ausbildung angefangen.
Hatte aber keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich BWL über alles hasse irgendwie.
Und noch schlimmer, irgendwelche BWL-Leute, die so extrem Stonks denken.
Ach so, stimmt.
Wir wollten das Video gucken.
Lul.
Wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Da.
Okay.
Also, exzellent.
Ja, 50G.
50G Titanfall 2.
Ja.
Da habe ich sogar auf Twitter rumgeflamet damals.
Was hältst du von den Google-Kursen?
IT-Automation mit Python.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kenn ich nicht.
Boy, in fact 2014 seemed to be the dawn of thickness.
Wolfenstein new order, advanced warfare.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
In 2014?
War das, war das echt so?
Äh, Splixer, das weiß ich gerade nicht mehr.
Das hat irgendjemand im Chat geschrieben.
Vielleicht kann das derjenige im Chat wieder schreiben.
Aber GTA ist doch auch riesig und keiner weint.
Ja, gut, GTA hat viele Fanboys.
Außerdem hat GTA extrem viel Inhalt.
Ich glaube, da denken die Leute nicht so dran.
Dabei macht es gar keine große Unterschiede.
Die Sache ist halt die, das wäre überhaupt kein Problem,
wenn die Spiele so groß wären.
Weil man ganz im Ernst an lokalem Speicherplatz auf dem PC wohlgemerkt,
scheitert es nicht.
Ja, wenn du bei Xbox One guckst zum Beispiel,
da ist es natürlich ein bisschen knapp und auch bei den neuen vielleicht.
Aber auf dem PC scheitert es wirklich nicht an Speicherplatz.
Das Problem, was wir in Deutschland haben, ist,
dass der Breitbandausbau so scheiße ist.
Übrigens, wusste ihr eigentlich, dass wir 50 MBit für jeden Haushalt
bis Ende 2018 schaffen?
Wusstet ihr das schon?
Dass bis 2018 schaffen wir das?
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was die aktuellen Ziele sind.
Mr. Twachs, ich mache das schon eine Weile.
Ich meine 2018, die haben 2018 gesagt.
Und ich habe sogar darauf geantwortet
und die Telekom hat irgendwas Doofes zurückgeschrieben,
so nach dem Motto,
wir sind die Nummer 1 im Netzausbau,
oder irgendwie so nichts zu einem Kram.
Die wollen jetzt schon Richtung 6G gehen.
Ja, ich werfe für 69G endlich mal.
Also das wollen wir ein bisschen schnellere Fortschritte machen.
Ja, das sagt.
Das ist ein bisschen laut.
Ja, gut.
Also mal, Warzone und Modern Warfare,
die haben mir den Vogel abgeschossen.
Das ist wirklich nicht, was die da alles rein...
Gut, ich meine, doch, ich weiß es letztendlich,
es besetzt sich aus dem zusammen,
was ich vorhin erzählt habe, unter anderem.
Aber, also da hat es für mich echt so gewirkt,
als hatten sie einfach keinen Bock.
Als haben einfach 3 verschiedene Teams zusammengearbeitet,
3 Sachen erstellt, die nicht zusammenpassen,
und dann hat man alles zusammen in einen Downloadordner gepackt.
Und die haben in Modern Warfare ja auch diese Geschichte,
dass wenn du eine Datei änderst,
in diesem Modern Warfare-Zip oder was das ist,
dann musst du irgendwie den Chunk runterladen.
Ein Chunk ist irgendwie 17 Gigabyte oder sowas.
Ja, Kofax, genau das mache ich jetzt total.
Egal, wir, wir auf jeden Fall.
Was für eine Leitung hast du?
Das ist eine gute Frage. 400 MBit glaube ich.
Ja, das stimmt.
Battlefield 3 ist glaube ich mit allen DLCs 40G oder so.
Oh, Big Brain Modder.
Gut, da muss ich ja mal dazu sagen,
ich glaube Modern Warfare hat,
haben die überhaupt richtige Cutscenes im Singleplayer gehabt?
Oder war das In-Game-Grafik?
Ne, die hatten Cutscenes, ne?
Die hatten Cutscenes, ja.
Sogar, sogar glaub gar nicht, so wenig?
Ja klar, das braucht, ja.
Ist ja im Prinzip das, was ich vorhin auch gesagt habe, klar.
Das braucht.
Ja, AV1 wird da auch nichts ändern.
Außerdem ist wieder die, bei AV1 ist wieder die Frage,
ob sie da die Kurve kriegen.
Bzw. H265.
Oh, Hi-Res.
Hi-Res.
Icon.
Ja.
Moment, ich bringe ich das gerade durch?
Ist AV1, H265?
So, das ist wieder was anderes.
Dann blick ich nicht mehr durch.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen AV1 und H265?
Ist das der Nachfolger von, also ist AV1 quasi H266?
Ach, Lizenzfrei, okay.
Ja, dann hast du das Problem, dass wahrscheinlich wieder keiner dahinter steht.
So ein bisschen wie bei diesen ganzen lossless compression Sachen, die es gibt.
Wo es auch nur eine Referenzimplementierung gibt und keiner es großartig unterstützt.
Naja, gut.
Also wenn da Intel, Apple und Netflix dabei ist,
Netflix ist jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Wichtig wäre noch, dass Nvidia und vielleicht AMD dabei wären.
Für Hardware-Encoder, Decoder in der Grafikade.
Weil das Intel am Start ist, ist auch schon mal gut.
Dann hat das ja durchaus seine Chancen, ja.
Wobei ich jetzt mal ehrlich sagen muss, ich persönlich bin ja H264-Fan,
weil jeder Furz mittlerweile einen H264-Decoder oder Encoder dabei hat.
Raspberry Pis, Tablets, aktuelle Intel-CPUs, Grafikkarten können,
was weiß ich, wie viele H264-Streams die kauen gleichzeitig.
Mr. Twax, das ist schön zu hören.
Er schreibt, ich habe, glaube ich, noch nie so viel an einem Stream gelernt wie in dem Livestream.
Exzellent.
Das liegt aber auch nicht nur an mir.
Das liegt auch daran, weil wir Big Brain Chat haben.
Das wollte ich hier, jetzt wo ich sehe,
das ist auch ein Game, was ich schon ewig mal spielen wollte.
Also nicht Dead or Alive, Titten Schaukel-Game, sondern das hier.
Ist das nicht Dings? Ist das nicht Kingdom Come?
Das wollte ich seit Ewigkeiten mal spielen.
Ich habe es sogar gekauft, runtergeladen.
Ich hatte es sogar schon mal zwischenzeitlich installiert.
Aber ich habe es nie gespielt.
Ja, Chat, Chat, benehmt euch oder ihr müsst euch What's New in PHP 8 angucken.
trainer
da ist es ja fast schon oder einer der schlimmsten da ist es ja fast schon normal ich meine du hast das game gekauft du
kaufst dir jedes add-on du bezahlst monatlich geld du bezahlst geld für character transfers für level boost für alles
und dann hast du noch einen in game shop
Für zeug also die übertreiben es echt
Das sieht aus wie ein game für phisio baro gemacht
Once again install to all owners of the base game even the free to play core fighters version with four characters and if your instinct is one dress couldn't be that big remember it's not just a dress it's a 4k dress multiply that hundreds of times and it explains how a game so simplistic on the surface can dwarf those with larger worlds according to r6 loop rainbow six siege has one thousand four hundred
Und wenn ich am anfang gar nicht daran gedacht der scheiß braucht halt auch speicher
Und je nachdem wie das gemacht ist mal richtig viel oder wenig es ist halt die frage wenn du hier wenn du hier nen box helm kaufst kaufst du also kriegst du dann haben die das so dynamisch gemacht dass du quasi die klamotten an hast und nur den box helm oder lädt der immer den komplett das komplette model mit
also quasi ist das hier wirklich nur der helm der drüber gezogen wird oder wird irgendwie quasi das komplette model ausgetauscht die ganzen oberflächen textur und sonst was keine ahnung kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an wie das game das gemacht hat ich würde ja sagen besser wäre es für alle wenn das nur der kop ist der ausgetauscht wird aber ja man weiß es nicht
das ist nicht groß ein bisschen geometrie zeug da ich glaube so levels sind da nicht das problem
ja und das ist halt auch die sache es kehrt halt keiner das ist das was ich auch am anfang gemacht habe es juckt halt keinen mehr die sagen halt auch gerade wenn man mal auf pc guckt die sagen halt ey leute habt ihr halt gefälligte 2 terabyte plus ssd rest juckt mich nicht
ja und gerade im hinblick auf konsolen ist der punkt wo ich nicht ganz verstehe weil im großteil der sachen passiert eben auf konsole wahrscheinlich denken die sich einfach dann installiert halt plus zwei games solange unser game auf der platte bleibt ist ja alles gut
man kann es davon abgesehen mp3s decoden oder was auch immer man da nimmt das braucht doch fast nix oder ich mein mp3s decoden kannst du heute auf dem tascherechner gefühlt
die simply made the high texture pack an optional download meaning they were originally going to force everybody to download a hundred and seventy five gigabytes for settings the majority of consumers wouldn't be able to run even if they wanted to considering how many people with high-end machines pursue framing or die map sagt leute die map ich habe das spiel nicht gespielt nur beta und das war eine map in der beta und die map war so kacke da ist riano kiefs
die people with high-end machines pursue framing over texture quality die map ist immer noch so scheiße die ging die ging
ja ok das stimmt
Die Spiele werden meist in großen Städten von jungen Leuten und Technik-Hubs entwickelt,
wo jeder Fiber-Optik hat und die Download-Speed nie ein Konzern ist.
Außerdem gibt es noch ein paar Idioten, die ein Spiel verweigern,
die sich für ein kleines Spiel verweigern, die sich für ein kleines Spiel verweigern, die sich für ein kleines Spiel verweigern.
Ja, das passiert tatsächlich.
Es gibt halt schon sticker wrists.
um ein Spiel zu verweigern, wenn es ein kleines Downloadsizei ist.
Ja, das passiert tatsächlich.
Also, es gibt viele Gründe, warum die Spiele heute
literally getting bigger and bigger.
Die ihre Logged-in-Plattform wollen.
Das ist genauso wie, warum gibt es einen Google Store,
einen Microsoft Store, einen Apple Store,
wo kein anderer was großartig machen kann
auf der jeweiligen Plattform.
Ja, warum gibt es, warum gibt es Kameras,
warum gibt es Überwachungskameras für meinen Garten,
wo ich eine Gebühr bezahlen muss,
dass ich mit dieser Kamera aufnehmen kann.
Oder, dass ich mir Aufnahmen runterladen kann.
Oder, dass ich überhaupt Aufnahmen machen kann.
Oder, du kannst 30 Milliarden Sachen fragen in der Richtung,
weil die alle ein Stückchen abhaben wollen
und die Leute in ihre Plattformen
Vendor-Login machen wollen.
Und die fuckt das ja richtig ab.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wir waren auf der Gamescom
auf so einer G2A-Präsentation.
Die waren richtig gerade im, also wie soll ich sagen,
so richtig im EA hat G2A geflammt und G2A hat EA geflammt.
Also, die haben halt eine Statistik gezeigt,
dass auf G2A mehr EA-Spiele verkauft werden
als auf Origin selbst.
Und das hat halt EA nicht gefallen.
Letztendlich brauchst du ja immer noch Origin,
um das zu spielen, ja.
Aber die Hersteller hätten halt gerne,
dass du es auch auf Origin kaufst.
Und der Trend geht ja da eindeutig
auch die letzten Jahre über hin.
Also, physische Datenträger sind out.
Keys im klassischen Sinne.
Mögen die Hersteller auch nicht mehr so.
Dann gibt es noch Leute, die gerne Gift-Cards kaufen
und Playstation Gute haben und Zeug.
Nicht nur die indischen Scammer,
die erzählen, dass man Google Gift-Cards kaufen muss,
um ihnen das Geld zurück zu überweisen.
Ja, die wollen alle was von abhaben.
Und eine Sache, wo man vor Jahren gesagt hat,
das ist so ein bisschen zusammengesponnen
und Zukunft, wo es sich hin entwickeln könnte,
gut ist, hat man jetzt ja.
Es werden kaum noch Spiele gebraucht verkauft, zum Beispiel.
Weil es keine gebrauchten Spiele in dem Sinn mehr gibt.
Es gibt nur noch Spiele, die an irgendeinen Account gebunden sind.
Und wenn es das mal nicht ist,
dann wird nach der Installation
beim ersten Mal einloggen in Multiplayer eben
verlangt, dass man das an einen Account bindet.
Dann kann man zwar die CD weiter verkaufen,
aber den Multiplayer müssen die Leute extra kaufen
und so was in der Richtung.
Das ist halt vorbei, ja.
Und ich meine, man sieht es ja,
dass das alle irgendwie probieren, ja.
Ich meine, die Epic hat mit ihrem Epic-Launcher jetzt auch angefangen.
Was ja ganz witzig ist,
das sind auch die, die gegen Google Store was haben.
Also irgendwie witzig, ne.
Auf der einen Seite forcieren sie ihren Epic-Launcher
mit Exclusives,
aber dann verklagen sie Google oder Apple.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Ich glaube, Google.
Dass Google zu viel Geld von Fortnite abbekommt.
Das ist irgendwie...
Ich meine, war es Apple?
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe mir ein Bild, das war Google,
aber ja, doch, es könnte auch Apple gewesen sein.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Ist halt witzig, ne.
Die, die gerade dafür sorgen, dass viele Sachen
jetzt Epic-Exclusives sind, haben keinen Bock.
Aber denen geht es ja.
Und was ich dann immer geil finde,
die machen, die bauschen das dann so auf,
so nach dem Motto, als machen die das jetzt
für die Community und für die Entwickler und bla.
Das ist höchstens ein Abfallprodukt.
Die machen das erste Mal und vornehmlich für sich selbst,
dass es mehr Geld gibt.
Ja, free Fortnite, genau.
Solche Dinger, solche Dinger,
da versucht man halt noch die Community
für seine Zwecke einzuspannen.
Und da muss man sich halt mal überlegen,
auf der einen Seite tun sie immer so,
wir lieben unsere Spieler und die beste Community.
Und dann spannt man die Leute ein
unter falscher Flagge quasi.
So nach dem Motto, man gibt vor,
man macht das jetzt irgendwie für die Community
und man ist voll geil.
Und ehrlicherweise muss man halt sagen,
man macht das für die eigenen Stonks,
für nichts anderes.
Free Fortnite, wisst ihr an was mich das erinnert?
Könnt ihr euch noch an Freiheit für Unge erinnern?
Das war auch so ein Ding.
Die Leute, wie sie da rumgespammt haben, Alter.
Ich hab mir damals ja auch schon gedacht,
da muss man halt gucken, was man unterschreibt, ne?
Aber da ist, ich mein, ich weiß das aus erster Hand,
was da bei YouTube Netzwerken für ne Scheiße läuft.
Ich hatte ja auch das Vergnügen am Anfang mal,
so ein Kacknetzwerk zu landen.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass mein Netzwerk jetzt nicht kacke ist,
oder so. Ich weiß nicht, was die treiben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die jetzt mittlerweile heißen,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab mit denen aber nichts zu tun.
Solange die irgendwelche Stonks und Content-Dinger
von meinem Kanal frei halten, bleib ich da erstmal.
Bei welchem Netzteil bist du jetzt?
War mal TubeOne, ich weiß nicht, wo TubeOne jetzt dazu gehört.
Blick da nicht mal durch.
Naja, so, gucken wir mal weiter, jetzt ist das Video.
Genau.
Und, nix ordentlich optimiert.
Das muss man ja echt mal bei Warzone sagen.
Also Warzone ist ein Spiel,
ich weiß wirklich nicht,
wie die das hinbekommen,
das,
ich weiß gar nicht,
wie die das hinbekommen,
das,
ich weiß gar nicht,
wie die das hinbekommen,
das,
fühlt sich mit 90 FPS so an,
wie andere Spiele mit 30.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das machen.
Bestimmt.
Naja, man könnte,
man könnte ja einfach eine Option anbieten.
Das geht, das geht.
Übrigens, Modern Warfare ist das einzige Game,
was beim Starten immer irgendwelche Sachen
noch mal extra laden,
kompilieren oder was auch immer musste.
Keine Ahnung, das hab ich bei keinem anderen Game gesehen.
Nee, nicht die Refresh Rate vom Server.
Ich mein wirklich, wie sich das Game anfühlt.
Vom Lokal,
vom Responsive,
vom wie sich alles anfühlt.
Fühlt sich teilweise echt an
mit 90 FPS wie 30 FPS in anderen Games.
Von den Servern reden wir mal gar nicht.
Das ganz einfach, das ganz einfach.
Warum wir das nicht können? Das ganz einfach.
Weil es Entwicklungsaufwand ist, der sich nicht rechnet.
Ja.
Das ist so.
Pff.
Uuuuuh.
Also, klingt jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen weit hergeholt,
aber nicht ganz unrealistisch.
Das ist ja auch der Grund,
warum das Game so einfach ist.
aber nicht ganz unrealistisch
ich mein das könnte sich
das könnte man ganz einfach fixen
ich mein die konsolenhersteller
machen ja schon eine gewisse
ich setz mal Qualitätskontrolle
beziehungsweise Kontrolle ob das Spiel
alles einhält was es für Vorgaben gibt
die Konsolenhersteller
könnten da mit Sicherheit einen Riegel vorschieben
wenn ihr wollt
und das ist ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung
jetzt bin ich nicht naiv
sie haben das ausgewertet
die average Downloadspeed in Amerika ist
50,2 Megabit pro Sekunde
die aktuellsten Konsolen starten
mit 1440p und mehr als 35%
von US Haushalten haben eine 4k
Televison
die Demand für hochqualititie Aspekte existieren
und große Marken haben die Infrastruktur
um es zu erzielen
wie die 8. Generation wo die
Konsolen von den Firmen
komplett weg von dem
Markt sind
jetzt planten sie die Seelen früh
aber diese Investitionen für die Zukunft
erzielen keine Probleme
in der Vergangenheit
Amerika hat Plätze mit schnellen Internet
es gibt auch die mit keinem Broadband
die Stadt mit einem Single Service Provider
und Verbindungen, die nicht stabiler sind als
die MAKOS Physik
Gott helfe dir, wenn du ein Entwickler
in diesen Bereichen leben
was gefragt wird ist nicht unwahrscheinlich
wir haben Optional Texture Packs
wir haben mehrere Cutscenes
und wir haben Modes gesektioniert
warum nicht diese
ein Standard machen
Piraten haben das schon seit Jahren
gemacht
wenn du die Konsolen über Resolution
und Kontrollern lassen wirst
was ist das für eine Musik im Hintergrund
du denkst das ist gerade ein krasser
Boss Fight am Start
...
zu zu sagen außer dass halt wie wie immer
Es wird abgewogen was lohnt sich
Das ist ja auch eine geschichte das ich kann mich noch dran erinnern das habe ich damals sogar mit kaboom in irgendeinem video erzählt
Dass die hersteller oder die entwickler studios und die publisher
Vieles mitbekommen wo die leute denken die bekommen es nicht mit und warum denken die leute sie bekommen es nicht mit weil sie nicht
drauf reagieren aber vieles ist
ist
Genauso was wie skill based matchmaking zum beispiel oder gewisse nuptube geschichten in games oder oder sachen sind da
absichtlich drin
Die sind nicht drinnen um die leute abzufacken oder oder weil die weil die es nicht besser wissen
Das ist absichtlich geplant drin um einen gewinnt eine bestimmte aufgabe zu erfüllen
Was im endeffekt unterm strich immer heißt bringen die leute dazu mehr geld auszugeben
Genau normales stand genau
Das ist auch so was genauso was no more last and fuck you last and und dann ist final stand drinnen und märthe
Dorm und alles mögliche ist halt so und warum ist das drin damit der letzte kacken und mannen kill macht
Warum ist skill based matchmaking drin und jetzt kommt tatsächlich ein bisschen bisschen verschwörungstheorie
Wahrscheinlich um
Die leute so zu matchen dass eben die optimale ausbeute an waffen käufen kisten käufen skin käufen passiert
Und mit sicherheit mit sicherheit auch weil man das spielerverhalten analysiert hat und so versucht quasi
die spieler möglichst lange
Am game zu halten was natürlich nicht
Also muss ich mal sehen was natürlich nicht bedeutet dass das dazu führt dass richtig krasse
Spieler dadurch jetzt dieses game acht stunden am stück spielen werden weil richtig gute spieler sind von skill based matchmaking abgefuckt
aber denen geht es ja darum dass der durchschnitt gesteigert wird die spielen
So und wenn halt die ganzen kack noobs
normalerweise nur 20 minuten spielen und die guten leute vier stunden und die guten leute spielen durch skill based matchmaking zwei stunden aber die kack noobs spielen eine stunde
Und es gibt da viel mehr kack noobs oder oder halt casuals oder wie auch immer man es nennt dann haben sie dadurch gewonnen und spielzeit
Müsste man mal gucken ob es dazu eine statistik gibt aber ich bin mir da relativ sicher
spielzeit dürfte ziemlich
Zu ziemlich eins zu eins korrelieren mit verkauften sachen
Wier are popular in den
Ja, wenn es monitorisiert ist wahrscheinlich oder November
Ist aber schlecht
Ja mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich mein, wenn ich jetzt ein Nintendo Game streame, was soll ich denn machen, ja?
Max, kennst du Onlyfans? Wer kennt heutzutage nicht Onlyfans?
Onlyfans kennt doch seit Belden vielen, Gamer Girl, Badewasser, jeder mittlerweile.
Die Sache ist die, ich hab letztens mal geguckt, es gibt ja ein paar Seiten mit, das werde ich wahrscheinlich in Zukunft auch machen, mit so Streamsave oder Copyright Free Music, da ist halt vieles ziemlicher Müll dabei.
Max, machst du Onlyfans? Was soll ich denn auf Onlyfans posten? Mach mal einen Vorschlag.
Äh, Gesichtsspiegelung, Leaks. Ich könnte es wieder Bauer machen, ich mach mal eine eigene Wärmeleitpaste.
Suppenleaks, ja exzellent.
Ok, guck mal weiter, was guck mal das nächstes an.
2021 Technologietrends und Predictions für Entwickler. Schauen wir mal.
Was hast du von kurz gesagt? Nice Animationen. Ich gucke relativ wenig Videos, aber die, wenn ich so gucke, finde ich die eigentlich immer gut gemacht.
Ok, mal gucken, was 2021 uns erwarten wird. F für Docker, oh ja, das glaube ich auch. F für Docker wird uns erwarten. Lass mal kurz in mich gehen. Was erwartet uns in der Technologiewelt 2021?
Flutter, also wenn es mal um Entwicklungs-Sachen geht. Flutter, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Flutter hat ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich Fahrt drauf.
Äh, und was denn sonst noch? Flutter. Weiterhin jede Menge JavaScript auf jeden Fall. JavaScript ist das Ding schlechend, es ist nicht umsonst so mit die meistverbreitste Programmiersprache überhaupt.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die ganze Machine Learning-Geschichte weitergehen wird. Voll Dampf, wie jetzt auch schon. Was ist Flutter? Ja, das da. Das ist ein GUI-Framework von Google.
Java wird weiterhin Bedeutung haben, gerade weil in China Java ziemlich beliebt ist. Es gibt Flutter für Desktop, aber ich glaube, das ist noch nicht so richtig gut.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mir das angeguckt habe, haben zum Beispiel noch ein Webview gefehlt, also sprich, man konnte keine HTML-Inhalte richtig darstellen, was natürlich Fail ist, was brauchst du heutzutage. Tja. C und C++ werden endgültig abgelöst und zwar von Rust und D. Nein, das wird nicht passieren.
Das wird nicht passieren. Go wird wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin ein bisschen... Was könnten so die krassen Developer-Trends und Technik-Trends 2021 werden? Das ist eigentlich fast wert, da ein Video drüber zu machen.
Jetzt muss ich mir mal aufschreiben. PHP 8 kommt raus. Ja, PHP 8. Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Not very much happened in 2020. Bootstrap 5 was released. A star disappeared. Angular added a new date picker.
Was war das mit dem Stern, der verschwunden ist? Da habe ich glaube ich ein Video zugesehen. Warte mal, ich glaube meine Katze will ins Zimmer rein. Ich mache mal kurz die Tür auf.
Oh, ich werde beschleimt. Was ist denn los? Willst du was haben?
Katze schleimt. Nice sound effects. So, okay, gucken wir mal.
Angular added a new date picker. Sie haben ja auch angeblich einen Alien-Raumschiff gefunden, was um die Erde kreist. Es ist aber wahrscheinlich nur eine alte Raketenstufe von uns selber.
Ach, View 3 gab es ja auch. Wusstet ihr, dass die SpaceX Terminals mit JavaScript laufen? Da war ich echt überrascht von.
Aber das witzige ist, jeder Knopf hat, also jeder Knopf, es gibt noch einen Knopf für alle Funktionen und man braucht ja die Panels gar nicht. Die sehen einfach nur gut aus.
Okay, dann schieß mal los.
Home Office. Ja, ja, das wird nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall noch mehr kommen.
Außer bei uns, da sind sie ja immer noch der Meinung, die Leute sollen auf die Arbeit kommen.
Also, die meisten machen das nicht, aber irgendeiner von unseren Vorstandsleuten hat mal gesagt, ja, wir sind eine Bank für Menschen und kümmern uns um Menschen.
Deswegen müssen Menschen auch vor Ort sein oder irgendwie so komische Dinge. Dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, Alter, was ist da wieder los?
Und als dann die letzte Corona-Lockdown-Geschichte kam, da gab es ja dann schon ziemlich klare Empfehlungen nach dem Motto, jeder, der nicht auf die Arbeit gehen muss, der soll halt völlig zu Hause bleiben und so was. Und da gab es bei uns dann eine Mail, so eine Rundmail.
Und da stand dann sinngemäß sowas drin, wie unsere Hygienekonzepte greifen. Wir können so weitermachen wie bisher, so als wäre das jetzt was Tolles.
Und alle Leute haben sich so an den Kopf gegräbt und haben gesagt, keiner wollte so weitermachen wie bisher. Warum wird das jetzt verkauft, als wäre das jetzt was Gutes?
Sind die Manager auch solche Hacker-Mans wie du? Wir haben tatsächlich ein paar Hacker-Man-Manager. Da gibt es ein paar, die sind gar nicht schlecht in der Richtung.
Nee, aber bei uns kriegen sie das irgendwie nicht gebacken. Ich meine, ohne Mist, Leute. Also wenn ihr in einem wirklich richtig Oldschool- und Tragen-Unternehmen aber in wollt, dann müsst ihr bei einer Bank arbeiten.
Wir sagen zwar immer, wir sind so toll und die Besten und so agil, aber eigentlich sind wir es nicht. Wir feiern uns nur gerne.
Es ist nicht umsonst so, dass der ehemalige IT-Chef von der Deutschen Bank, oder was nicht so gerne IT-Chefin von der Deutschen Bank, die das zuletzt gemacht hat, die hat dann aufgehört oder so nach einem Jahr und meinte, die Deutsche Bank, und nein, ich arbeite nicht bei der Deutschen Bank, ich nehme das mal als Beispiel, die hatte keinen Bock mehr und hat gesagt, nachdem sie gekündigt hat, der Deutsche Bank wäre IT-mäßig das dysfunktionalste Unternehmen aller Zeiten.
Aber gucken wir mal weiter. Ja, das habe ich auch mitgekriegt.
Übrigens ein richtig cooler Trend, das wird man bei uns denke ich auch sehen, gerade in den Städten, die hatten in New York ja das riesen Problem, dass in New York die Apartment- und Kunststückspreise und Mietpreise und so, das war ja übertrieben hoch.
Und jetzt haben sie halt das Problem, dass die Leute da reinweise wegrennen und da war halt auch teilweise mega hohe Besteuerung und alles noch am Start und jetzt rennen die Leute reinweise weg und gehen aufs Land und irgendwo anders hin.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das teilweise bei uns auch passieren wird, weil es gibt bestimmt genug Leute, die wohnen zwar sagen wir mal in Frankfurt, die haben da aber eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Tomber, das ist was, was ich von vielen Leuten schon mitbekommen habe oder zumindest gelesen habe. Ich bin ja auch nicht der Allersozialste, was das angeht. Und zwar er schreibt, ich wohne alleine, muss echt sagen, dass ich seit Homeoffice gefühlt echt vereinsame.
Das habe ich von einigen jetzt schon gehört. Natürlich habe ich da jetzt keine ultimative Sache dagegen, ist ja logisch. Ich bin halt einfach jemand, der braucht relativ wenig soziale Kontakte.
Mir gehen eigentlich andere Menschen ehrlich gesagt eher hauptsächlich auf den Sack. Jetzt mal der Twitch-Chat ausgenommen. Aber ansonsten bin ich eigentlich froh, wenn ich nicht so viel Kontakt mit anderen Leuten haben muss.
Aber eine Sache, wo ich mir denke, dass das hilft, ist, fang den MMO an.
Probier mal, probier mal irgendein MMO zu spielen. Und ohne Mist, gerade je nachdem, was das für ein MMO ist, spiel Final Fantasy Dings, was ist das 14, wenn du auf Aja ja MMOs stehst.
Tja, wenn man das Genre nicht mag, dann spiel, keine Ahnung, spiel Competitive, Counter-Strike und Flame nicht den ganzen Tag mit Leuten. Das weiß ich.
Aber ich muss halt sagen, MMOs ist halt im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen Competitive-Ranked-Geschichten viel netter.
So WoW bin ich mir nicht so sicher. WoW hast du auch viele Spasten, aber das ist halt WoW. Aber gerade von Final Fantasy XIV habe ich viel Gutes gehört.
Wobei ich aber auch sagen muss, auch da gibt es Spasten. Ich habe das ja mit dem Friseur gespielt eine ganze Weile.
Und da hast du auch so die richtigen, möchte gern Hardcore-Typen in Daily-Instances und sowas.
Ich denke mir immer, ich spiele irgendeinen MMO und mache hier gerade als wäre es ESL-Final in so einer normalen Public-Instance.
Wenn du voll der Neuling in MMOs bist, bist du doch super.
Also ich denke mal, ich kann jetzt keins empfehlen, weil ich auch schon eine Weile außer Free-Shard, ich habe Dark Age of Camelot auf dem Free-Shard gespielt, allerdings ist das nichts, was ich empfehlen würde für neue Leute.
Ich denke mal, das Beste ist, was man wirklich machen kann, aktuell ist es tatsächlich.
Es ist ja jetzt gerade eine neue World of Warcraft Addon rausgekommen, tatsächlich mal mit World of Warcraft anfangen.
Und ohne Mist, ich sag dir mal was es ist, also es ging mir ja früher auch so ein bisschen, wo ich viel MMO gespielt habe.
Das hilft echt, das hilft echt, wenn man so ein bisschen Kontakt hat, ein bisschen Kontakt zu Leuten haben will, ein bisschen schwätzen will oder so.
Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass ich den ganzen Tag eingeloggt war in MMOs und die MMOs als Chatbox missbraucht habe.
Also das hilft schon. So, gucken wir das mal fertig jetzt.
Ich meine natürlich gibt es immer noch die Möglichkeit, dass man Leute, die man kennt, irgendwie online zusammenspielt und so.
Aber wüsste ich, mit wem ich das machen soll, außer halt vielleicht mit dem Friseur, ja.
Und dazu fehlt uns das richtige Game. Okay.
Das stimmt. Ja, da hat er Recht. Da hat er Recht, seh ich auch so.
Wenn es jetzt nicht mehr drauf ankommt, dass man vor Ort ist, ist man automatisch im Wettbewerb mit allem anderen auf der Welt, die diesen Job machen können.
Ja, da hat er Recht.
Du tauscht YouTube immer auf Englisch. Naja, es gibt halt nicht so viele gute deutsche Channels, die ich gerne gucke, ne.
Ja, das liegt da dran, weil die nicht genug Leute bekommen.
Ist auch immer so. Wenn du nicht genug Leute bekommst, dann musst du halt einfach die Anforderungen kleiner machen oder ausweiten, dass sie genug Leute bekommen.
Ist halt so, ne.
Hattest du schon mal Impostor-Syndrom? Was für ein Ding? Was? Was? Was für ein Ding?
Okay, das muss schon.
Das Hochstapler-Syndrom, teilweise auch Impostor-Syndrom.
Mogelpackung oder Betrüger-Phänomen genannt ist ein psychologisches Phänomen, bei dem Betroffene von massiven Selbstzweifeln hinsichtlich eigener Fähigkeit, Leistung und Erfolge geplagt werden und unfähig sind.
Ja, hat doch jeder irgendwann mal, oder?
Das hatte doch jeder schon mal irgendwann.
Ich hab das manchmal auch, wenn ich mir Videos von mir angucke, da frag ich mich, ey, was erzählst du da eigentlich überhaupt?
Oder wenn ich mir irgendwelche Sachen angucke, die ich mal programmiert hab, dann denk ich mir auch manchmal, alter, ich hätt gar keine Ahnung, wie man sowas macht.
Und dann fällt mir auf, ja gut, ich hab das doch schon mal gemacht vor einem halben Jahr oder so.
Aber ja, das hat doch jeder irgendwann mal.
Dass man da irgendwie Zweifel daran hat, ob man Sachen auf die Reihe kriegt.
Schlimmer ist das Gegenteil, oh ja, da gibt's auch Leute.
Da gibt's auch Leute.
Da haben wir auf der Arbeit viele.
Die können sich gut verkaufen, zumindest die ersten fünf Minuten, und dann merkst du halt, merkst eigentlich schon instant, dass sie keinen Plan haben.
Wir hatten ja mal, ich hab euch ja mal vor unserem Premium Azubi erzählt, der der Git als Shit ausgesprochen hat.
Der konnte auch eine Sache wirklich gut, nein, nein, ich würde mich hier mal ein eigenes Video angucken.
Der konnte auch eine Sache richtig gut.
Die ersten fünf Minuten konnte er sich selbst richtig gut verkaufen.
Der ist jetzt Junior Consultant, ja.
Der konnte sich die ersten fünf Minuten richtig gut verkaufen, weil der hatte ein richtig gutes Talent.
Was glaube ich für Stonks-Menschen echt gut ist.
Und zwar der mit dem Nerven, genau der.
Ich hoffe, der guckt hier nicht streamen, das wäre bestimmt ultra peinlich, dass ich das erzählt hab.
Wollte jetzt sagen, dass, genau.
Und der hat ein riesen Talent gehabt, der Typ.
Und zwar, der konnte, also der konnte anfangen zu erzählen und hatte noch ein bisschen Ahnung von dem Thema.
Aber irgendwann kam dann der Punkt, wo die Ahnung aufgehört hat.
Und der hat es geschafft, diesen Punkt nicht wahrnehmbar zu machen.
Also normalerweise merkst du es bei den Leuten immer.
Sobald Leute anfangen, quasi aus dem bekannten Gebiet, wo sie sich auskommen, wo sie anfangen, sich was auszudenken, das merkste meistens.
Bei dem hast du es nicht gemerkt.
Der konnte quasi, on the fly, reden von, ich hab noch Ahnung davon zu, ich denk mir jetzt grad was aus.
Und du hast das nicht gemerkt, dass er jetzt gewechselt ist von, ich hab Ahnung zu, ich hab keine Ahnung, denk mir was aus.
Das Problem war nur, wenn es um irgendwelche technischen Sachen ging, womit ich mich auskannte, hab ich natürlich sofort gemerkt, dass der irgendeinen Müll erzählt.
Und das hab ich dann auch einmal gesagt, hab gesagt, es kann doch nicht sein, wir haben uns das jetzt eine Woche lang angeguckt.
Also wir haben uns eine Woche lang was angeguckt zusammen, so Netzwerk Basics.
Und da hab ich ihn am Freitag ein bisschen gelöchert, wie es denn jetzt damit ist, wie es jetzt damit ist, was passiert, wenn zwei Rechner miteinander kommunizieren, sonst was.
Und da hat er doch tatsächlich als Antwort gesagt, also er hat gesagt, nee, weiß ich nicht.
Da hab ich halt gemeint, jetzt haben wir doch die ganze Woche gemacht. Ja, aber ich weiß es doch nicht.
Und dann meinte er wirklich zu mir, ja, Max ist doch jetzt egal.
Da hab ich halt gemeint, das kann doch jetzt nicht sein.
Wir haben uns das eine Woche angeguckt, du kannst jetzt nicht einfach zu mir sagen, das ist egal, das ist jetzt nicht egal.
Wozu haben wir das die Woche gemacht? Und da war er voll fertig mit den Nerven danach.
Das war dann nicht gewohnt, dass man es merkt, dass er keine Ahnung hat.
Oder aber es könnte auch sein, dass ihm dort zum ersten Mal gedämmert ist, dass er keinen Plan hat von dem, was er macht.
Wahrscheinlich beides in Kombination.
Der hat wirklich, das war der falsche Job für ihn.
Ich glaube als Junior Consultant, oder wahrscheinlich ist er mittlerweile auch normaler Consultant.
Ich wüsste, Consultant vom Namen her, ja, ist ja eigentlich jemand, den ich konsultiere, weil er, weil er, also rein vom Wort her, ich weiß, dass es nicht so ist.
Aber rein vom Wort her, ist ja ein Consultant jemand, den hole ich mir, den konsultiere ich.
Wenn ich auf diesem Gebiet nicht genug Expertise habe oder nicht genug Ahnung habe, dann hole ich mir einen Consultant, den konsultiere ich dann dazu und der erklärt es mir.
Oder macht es für mich oder was auch immer.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht so ist bei den meisten Consultants, ja.
Aber ich wüsste wirklich beim besten Willen nicht, wozu ich ihn konsultieren würde.
Außer vielleicht, wie man stylish Anzüge trägt, ja.
Dazu würde ich ihn konsultieren, ja.
Das konnte er gut.
Stylische Anzüge anhaben.
Ich glaube, das war das Einzige, was er wirklich gut konnte.
Und da muss man sagen, das ist ja schon mal schon von Zweide, Zweide gute Voraussetzung für so eine Stonks-Position.
Er hat auch damals gesagt, er zieht sich zur Präsentation immer Anzüge an, weil er sich dann sicherer fühlt.
Gibt es so Leute?
Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich Anzüge anziehen muss.
Aber gibt es Leute, die fühlen sich damit kompetenter?
Sie sind es nicht, aber sie fühlen sich kompetenter und vielleicht hilft es ja was.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir das Video noch kurz fertig, ich muss ins Bett.
Ja.
Was?
Okay, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Die Zeiten, wo jede Woche ein neues JavaScript-Framework rausgekommen ist, sind vorbei.
Das kommt vielleicht immer noch raus, aber es juckt keinen.
Könnt ihr euch noch mal eine Frage an Leute, die ein bisschen Frontendentwicklung haben.
Ich bin ja jetzt nicht hauptsächlich Frontendentwickler, aber könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern,
dass es jede Woche eine andere Variante gab, wie man seine Apps bundelt.
So von, was gab es dann?
Rollup, Webpack, Gulb, Dings, Krunt oder wie es hieß.
Dann gab es noch Brokkoli oder so Zeug, was Namen alles ey.
Alter ey.
Die haben, die haben wirklich, die haben wirklich, es gab jede Woche einen anderen,
es gibt doch jetzt auch noch so einen richtigen Trendy neuen Bundler, habe ich vergessen.
Dieser Zero-Config-Bundler gibt es ja.
Die haben wirklich jede Woche, kam irgendwas neues, jede Woche.
Und da hast du nicht mehr durchgeblickt.
Aber die Zeiten sind glücklicherweise vorbei.
Es ist jetzt mehr oder weniger Webpack.
Und ein paar Sachen.
Und bei JavaScript Frameworks ist es im Prinzip genau das, was er hier gezeigt hat.
Und zwar.
Es ist Angular, React, Vue.js.
Es gibt noch so ein paar Randerscheinungen, sowas wie Svelte oder JQuery.
JQuery gibt es immer noch.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass JQuery rein von Seiten, worauf das verwendet wird,
immer noch das mit Abstand beliebteste JavaScript Framework ist?
Sofern man das JavaScript Framework nennen kann.
Also es gibt, glaube ich, weit mehr Seiten, die JQuery beinhalten,
als Angular, React und Vue.js, Svelte und noch was zusammen wahrscheinlich.
War das nicht so, dass irgendwie, fragt mich nicht,
40% aller Webseiten JQuery enthalten oder sowas?
Es war eine irrsinnig große Nummer.
Okay, weiter.
F.
Gut, dass er es sagt.
Ja, ja.
Ember.
Ember gibt es ja auch noch.
Ember habe ich vor Jahren mal was mitgemacht.
Ja, hat es doch auch.
Oder will er jetzt wirklich behaupten, das hätte es nicht?
Also ich bin schon der Meinung, seit React die Hooks AP released hat,
sind keine Kinder mehr hungrig in Afrika.
Ist doch klar.
War doch logisch.
Ich meine, das ist von Facebook.
Was erwartet man denn auch sonst?
Ja, ja.
Echt?
Was ist das?
Also Leute, wenn man zu viel Fantasie hat,
da weiß ich nicht genau, wofür das hier steht.
Vor allem mit dem B vorne dran noch.
Aber wahrscheinlich interpretiere ich da zu viel rein gerade.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Das denke ich auch.
Ja.
Nur ich verwende es nicht.
Ja, aber ich denke auch, dass das weiter steigt.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Deno die wahnsinnige Verbreitung bekommen wird.
Und warum nicht?
Weil es keine NPM Packages unterstützt.
Und das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe,
konntest du in Deno keine NPM Packages verwenden.
Und gerade der so doof es klingt, weil es viele Schwachsinn-Packages gibt,
aber eines der größten Vorteile des ganzen JavaScript-Ökosystems sind eben NPM Packages.
Dass es so schwachsinnige Pakete wie IsOdd, IsEven gibt, sei mal dahingestellt,
aber es gibt halt einfach so nahezu alles in JavaScript.
Und wenn du das nicht verwenden kannst, ist halt fragwürdig, ob sich das durchsetzt.
Warum ich nicht?
Ja.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Außer auf iOS, weil Apple mit Safari die Sache wieder nicht hinbekommt.
Ja.
Wollte ich ja auch schon mal ausprobieren, schon lange.
Außer bei Apple, außer bei Apple, außer bei Apple, außer bei Apple.
Gut, Offline-Mode geht auch bei Apple.
Ja.
Warum wir das machen sollten, ist ganz einfach.
Weil die Casual-Noob-User im App-Store gucken.
Die werden auch weiter in dem App-Store gucken.
Und dementsprechend musst du im App-Store sein, wenn du Geld verdienen willst.
Ja, genau.
Bitte Fortnite als PVA und WebAssembly.
Let's go.
Je nachdem.
Wisst ihr, was das Bitzige ist?
Dass das, okay, mit Fortnite bin ich, bin ich sicher, aber dass das potenziell mit WebGPU
und WebGL und was nicht alles sogar potenziell geht mittlerweile.
Nein, glaube ich auch nicht.
Nein, glaube ich nicht.
Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Und wenn, ich lass ihn erstmal erzählen.
Ja, also, mit Fortnite und Mario 64-Port ist ja nur schon mal zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe.
Aber ja, es zeigt, wohin es geht.
Ja, gut.
Dass das passieren wird, glaube ich nicht, aber ich glaube aber, dass wir alle noch den Punkt erleben werden,
wo wir so gut geworden sind mit AI, dass wir anfangen, AI zu entwickeln, um AIs zu verbessern.
Und dass dann AIs sich selber verbessern und entwickeln.
Und natürlich, und natürlich alles, und natürlich alles in JavaScript.
Nee, aber ich glaube, das werden wir alle noch erleben und das wird nicht mal allzu lange dauern.
Und das ist der Punkt, wo wir wahrscheinlich einen riesen Geschwindigkeitszuwachs bekommen werden,
was neue Entwicklungen, Technologien und Sachen bekommen werden, wo man bisher gesagt hat,
die kannst du eigentlich mit dem Computer gar nicht machen oder nicht ordentlich machen.
Oder nicht so machen, wie man sich's vorstellt. Ich glaube, das werden wir aber alles mitkriegen.
Zeitspanne von Zehner, ja.
Es wird aber nicht so ablaufen, wie man sich das im Film vorstellt.
Also, da gibt's kein Skynet oder sowas.
Ach, Crap. Crap. Crap, Alter.
Kannst vielleicht ein Prototyp mitmachen, aber das ist Müll.
Crap.
Ja, okay, da hat er recht.
Aber ich halte...
Die letzten 20 Jahre erzählen die Leute schon, ja, man braucht bald keine Programmierer mehr,
weil dann die Stronx-Leute programmieren können in einem Click-Editor.
Das wird's nicht geben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist genau die Sache, hier Sirius Max sagt, wer macht den Click-Editor?
Das ist genauso wie die Sache, man braucht keine Leute mehr, die sich mit Server auskennen.
Ja, okay, und was machen die Cloud-Anpieter?
Klar, natürlich ist das zentrierter, da müssen wir nicht drüber reden.
Und so die klassischen, dass jeder einen Admin-Team, einen Monitoring-Team,
ein eigenes RZ hat, ein RZ-Team, die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Aber jetzt zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist auf einmal alles weg,
weil Cloud ist ein bisschen kurzfristig gedacht.
Mr. Thwack sagt, glaubst du daran, dass noch was erfunden wird,
wie das Internet was die Welt verändert?
Und wenn ich das Leute sage, lachen sie nur, ja, es wird laufend Sachen erfunden,
du schreibst ja selbst hier, guck dir Smartphones an,
oder wenn ich ein bisschen länger drüber nachdenke, gibt es da jede Menge Sachen,
die, Corona-Impfstoff zum Beispiel, gibt es da jede Menge Sachen,
es wird permanent Sachen erfunden, die die Welt verändern.
Ich meine, so wie das Internet nicht, weil, warum?
Es gibt ja das Internet, also da wird es wahrscheinlich nicht,
was wie das Internet nochmal gehen, weil es gibt ja jetzt schon was.
Ja, auf jeden Fall passiert laufend.
Ja, laufend passiert da was.
Ja, und es ist immer schwierig, das zu sehen,
weil vieles sieht man erst 50 Jahre später, dass das so bedeutend war.
weil vieles sieht man erst 50 Jahre später,
Wir haben uns schon lange damit verabschiedet.
Jetzt wollte ich meine schlimmste Prediktion für das letzte Mal retten.
Ich glaube, dass es möglich ist, dass wir ein Black Swan-Type-Event im Jahr 2021 sehen,
wie wir es im Jahr 2020 mit der Rona gemacht haben.
Als das Markt im März zurückgefallen ist,
hat es schnell wieder zurückgekommen zu All-Time-Highs in weniger als einem Jahr.
Die Wiederholung wurde durch die Technikindustrie
und durch Stimulus von der Regierung
und Geld-Printen von der Federal Reserve.
Tons und Tons von Technikerinnen und Technikerinnen
gingen während dieser Zeit öffentlich,
mit S-Packs für Spezial-Purpose-Kompeten.
Was?
Die Technikindustrie, die zu Hause geschlossen ist,
hat gelernt, wie man ein Tag-Träger werden kann.
Das scheint ziemlich einfach zu sein, wenn...
Der Stockmarkt geht nichts,
sondern hoch und hoch und hoch.
All das hat die Unternehmen mit verrückten Valuationen beteiligt.
Schauen Sie nur an die Unternehmen,
wie Snowflake, die dieses Jahr öffentlich waren.
100 Billionen Dollar Marktkap,
nur 400 Millionen in Revenu
und ein Verlust von 350 Millionen.
Und es gibt viele andere Stocks, die es so sind,
die kein Geld machen,
mit modestem Wachstum,
das kann nicht lange dauern.
Und dann wird es eine Art Katalysen,
um alles zu kraschen.
Unternehmen, die kein Wachstum machen,
können nur mit einem hohen Stockpreis
oder einer Verlust von Geld von irgendwo anderes überleben.
Wenn das Markt wieder krascht,
gibt es ein sehr hohes Potenzial für einen Jobloss in der Technikindustrie
und möglicherweise verlassenen Möglichkeiten für Unternehmende.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass ich falsch bin,
ich hoffe, dass die Partei 2021 weiter geht.
Mein YouTube-Kanal hat davon zu tun,
aber ich freue mich nur darauf,
dass die Zukunft vorhanden wird.
Ich bin ein Mitglied des Fireship.io
oder ich bin persönlich auf GitHub gesponsert.
Ich wollte nur sagen Danke an alle,
für daseleri.com,
2019 über Gamer Girl Badewasser geredet
als 1900 fragt mich nicht
70 über das Internet
also wenn es darum geht
Egal Leute, ich geh jetzt ins Bett, machts gut, wir sehen uns
also ich glaube ich mach auch so ein Video
ich glaube ich mach auch so ein Video
Technik Trends 2021
das ist bestimmt
eine gute Sache, also machts gut, bis denn
See you!